la sed se presenta como un político
centrista como un político que ofrece
continuidad de hecho es muy cercano a la
canciller angela merkel y apoyo a merkel
en una de sus posturas más
controversiales la de recibir refugiados
una crisis de 2015 la 7 es como ustedes
ya mencionaron también el líder del
estado de renania del norte-westfalia
que es el estado más poblado de alemania
con unos 18 millones de personas y eso
es algo que él sin duda ha presentado
como su fortaleza el haber liderado un
estado con una lucha con mucha
importancia en alemania la pregunta
ahora sin embargo es si la chet también
podrá convertirse en el candidato del
bloque conservador de cara a las
elecciones federales de septiembre eso
no es un proceso automático y de hecho
la pandemia ha elevado el perfil de
otros políticos ajenos a los tres
candidatos que intentaban ser líderes de
la cdu y por ello el debate que empieza
ahora es por un lado si la gente podrá
también ser el candidato del bloque
conservador a las elecciones de
septiembre
o si otros políticos como el ministro de
salud james banco el líder de baviera
macri solá podrían ocupar ese puesto
de hecho cuando se les pregunta a la
mayoría de los alemanes y también a la
mayoría de los simpatizantes de la cdu
ese perfil centrista que presentan láser
es algo que ellos quieren mantener y de
ahí que esto pueda ser visto por muchos
dentro de la cdu como una buena noticia
de cara a la carrera que marcará el
final de angela merkel en septiembre en
esas elecciones federales tan
importantes para alemania